Hallo ihr Lieben!
Heute geht es rund um das Thema Kurkuma und warum es so gesund ist, wie wir das zu uns nehmen können
und was ich jetzt aktuell in meine Routine mit eingeplant hab.
Also vorneweg: Ich bin natürlich keine Ärztin
aber ich informiere mich im Vorfeld immer extremst genau über ein Thema weil ich auch eine gewisse Verantwortung euch gegenüber habe.
Kurkuma ist extrem gesund und hat seinen Ursprung aus Indien.
Also in Indien - Das kenne ich sogar noch, 2012 war ich nämlich in Indien für einen Monat
und dort habe ich das erste Mal quasi die goldene Milch getrunken, da wurde sie genannt "Golden Latte".
Und es war gewöhnungsbedürftig aber mir wurde dann auch erklärt, wie gesund das ist.
Und zwar kann Kurkuma extrem entzündungshemmend wirken.
Das ist vor allem gut wenn ihr chronische Schmerzen habt wie z.B. Rückenschmerzen, Gelenkschmerzen, Arthrose, etc.
Kurkuma kann aber noch viel mehr als das.
Kurkuma kann außerdem verdauungsanregend sein und den Stoffwechsel ankurbeln.
Und eine Sache unter vielen, die bei mir persönlich so diesen Klick Moment ausgelöst haben,
dass ich das eigentlich täglich bei mir als Routine einplanen sollte,
ist, dass Kurkuma Antioxidantien enthält wie z.B. Glutathion.
Kurz ganz einfach und sehr vereinfacht erklärt:
Glutathion hilft, freie Radikale quasi zu bekämpfen wie so eine Art Polizei.
Und ihr wisst ja, oder habt vielleicht schon mal gehört, dass freie Radikale auch dazu führen können oder dazu führen,
dass der Körper Krebszellen entwickelt, etc.
Das kann auch an äußeren Einflüssen liegen wenn ihr z.B. Raucher seid oder euch nicht schlecht ernährt
oder einfach nicht so gut auf eure Ernährung achtet, dann werden diese freien Radikale eben auch freigesetzt.
Und da hilft Glutathion, dagegen anzukämpfen und das enthält eben Kurkuma.
Jetzt gibt's verschiedene Möglichkeiten, Kurkumin bei euch in den Alltag zu integrieren.
Entweder gibt's den ich sag mal "neumodischen" Weg in Form von Kapseln.
Da hab ich meine Bio Kurkuma Kapseln.
Die haben auch schon einen Anteil Bio Pfeffer drin enthalten, denn Pfeffer braucht ihr - bzw. einen Stoff aus dem Pfeffer -
um quasi die volle Wirkung von dem Kurkumin im Körper entfalten zu können.
Dann gibt's noch die traditionelle Variante, nämlich wie gesagt die goldene Milch.
Und da möchte ich euch jetzt einfach mal zeigen, wie ihr die goldene Milch Paste macht, also diese Kurkuma-Paste.
Und das ist so praktisch! Ich hab z.B. immer so ein Glas einfach im Kühlschrank, das hält dann 'ne Woche.
Und dann kann man sich davon immer so 'nen Teelöffel nehmen und sich morgens, mittags oder wann auch immer man möchte
die goldene Milch zubereiten. Und das zeige ich euch jetzt einfach mal.
Das allerallerwichtigste damit es überhaupt eine Wirkung bei euch erzielen kann, ist natürlich das Kurkuma und was es für eine Qualität hat.
Natürlich habt ihr bei meinem Kurkuma wie immer die beste Bio Qualität.
Das hört sich total werbungsmäßig an aber es ist so!
Also keine Farbstoffe, keine Konservierungsstoffe. 100%-iger Kurkuma in Bio Qualität aus Indien.
Das wird in Deutschland abgefüllt und daher haben wir auch die Möglichkeit -
Dadurch, dass es regional abgefüllt wird, haben wir die Möglichkeit, natürlich regelmäßige Kontrollen durchzuführen.
So und ich beginne jetzt einfach mal.
Ich hab jetzt hier meine Pfanne, da könnt ihr auch einen einfachen Topf nehmen.
Da gebe ich jetzt zuallererst Wasser rein, dann das Kurkumapulver, Pfeffer
und dann fange ich erstmal an, das Ganze klümpchenfrei zu verrühren
und danach schalte ich den Herd ein.
So, das Ganze habe ich jetzt auf Stufe 5 von 9 (also wirklich nur die mittlere Stufe) erwärmt.
Und dann merkt ihr so nach 2½ bis 3min, dass das Wasser verdampft und die Masse plötzlich richtig fest wird.
Und an der Stelle ist quasi die Paste fertig.
Und so hält die - je nachdem, wie viele Personen ihr im Haushalt seid -
So hält sie wirklich bis zu einer Woche im Kühlschrank.
Ich fülle das jetzt eben um, kann den Deckel da draufgeben und fertig. Also das ist jetzt die Paste.
Jetzt kommt die eigene goldene Milch und dafür verrührt ihr das in Milch.
Zur Milch muss ich euch noch was sagen: Gerade bei goldener Milch vermeide ich es, z.B. Kuhmilch zu nehmen.
Ich persönlich mag geschmacklich Hafermilch und Mandelmilch und Sojamilch nicht so gerne
aber es ist in dem Fall einfach gesünder, als es mit Kuhmilch zu nehmen
weil man sagt der Kuhmilch ja nach, dass sie schon Entzündungen hervorheben kann
und das wäre dann so - das hätte so einen gegenteiligen Effekt.
Daher hole ich eben meine Milch, mein Öl und dann geht's weiter.
So, jetzt geht's an die Zubereitung.
Ich hab jetzt hier meinen Topf und da gebe ich jetzt zuallererst die Kurkuma-Paste rein.
Ich schreibe euch auch in die Infobox, wieviel dann pro Portion quasi angemessen wäre.
Also das wäre jetzt ein halber Teelöffel, ich mache jetzt hier natürlich ein bisschen mehr.
So, da kommt dann die Milch rein, ich hab heute z.B. Hafermilch genommen.
Aber wie gesagt: Es gibt auch andere pflanzliche Milch.
Ich persönlich finde auch pflanzliche Milch hierfür am allerbesten geeignet.
So, einfach mit rein geben.
Jetzt musst du mal hier an den Topf kommen. Man sieht direkt, wie sich das nämlich gelb färbt.
[Hamza] Jetzt ist es schon gelb!
[Kiki] Ja, es hat jetzt schon so eine goldene Farbe.
An der Stelle habt ihr noch die Möglichkeit, verschiedene Gewürze mit reinzugeben, wie z.B. Nelken oder Kardamom etc.
Ich gebe jetzt einfach noch Zimt mit dazu, weil es auch antibakteriell wirkt.
Also nochmal einen zusätzlichen Effekt. So, und jetzt kommt das allerallerwichtigste!
Ich hab das in der Kombination so komischerweise noch gar nicht gesehen, auch wenn es total naheliegt!
Ihr braucht bei der goldenen Milch immer noch Fett. Ihr braucht unbedingt Fett.
Fett hilft einfach auch nochmal, dass bestimmte Vitamine freigesetzt werden,
dass der Körper nochmal ein bisschen was aufnimmt an Vitaminen
und ohne Fett habt ihr wirklich nur ganz, ganz wenig Wirkung, das ist genauso wichtig wie der Pfeffer.
[Hamza] Aber ist nicht Milch drin schon?
Milch ist auch drin aber die Milch hat nicht so viel Fett, als dass sie uns jetzt helfen kann.
Wir brauchen nochmal zusätzliches Fett.
Jetzt nehme ich - auf die Idee kamen wir beide praktisch gleichzeitig, als wir uns darüber unterhalten haben -
Wir nehmen Schwarzkümmelöl, es gibt nichts besseres!
Ihr wisst ja selber: Die Liste -
Wenn ich jetzt anfange, über Schwarzkümmelöl zu reden - das Video geht glaub ich 'ne Stunde oder so!
Dazu gibt's ein extra Video, das verlinke ich euch gerne.
Schwarzkümmelöl nehme ich tagtäglich ein, Hamza genauso. Jeden Tag einen Esslöffel.
Wenn ich es aber hier noch mit reingebe, kann das nur nochmal positive Wirkungen haben.
Denn es enthält Vitamine, ätherische Öle, tolle Nährstoffe - also es ist super, super gut für den Körper.
Und ich mache das jetzt so, dass ich das Ganze hier erstmal
sodass es sich verbindet erwärmen werde und im Anschluss gebe ich das Schwarzkümmelöl dazu.
Jetzt möchte ich euch aber noch eine Sache sagen denn ich weiß, dass die Frage aufkommen wird.
Wenn ihr jetzt die Kapseln nehmt: Da ist ja gar kein Öl drin, wie soll das wirken?
Da geht man einfach davon aus, dass ihr in eurer Nahrung schon Fette gegessen habt
und dann wirkt das eben genauso gut.
Falls ihr übrigens Fragen habt, schreibt's mir bitte unter das Video.
Ich lese immer wieder die Kommentare und kann sie euch dann beantworten.
[Hamza] Man kann auch dazu immer ganz gut Avocado essen finde ich.
Genau Avocado essen, genau! Ihr esst z.B. zum Frühstück 'ne Avocado, Kurkumakapseln rein und fertig!
Die goldene Milch hat sich jetzt richtig gut verbunden, das geht wirklich ganz schnell.
Und es ist auch in dem Fall egal, ob ihr Schwarzkümmelöl gefiltert oder ungefiltert nehmt.
Generell tut sich da nichts in der Wirkung, das ist komplett gleich.
Also dem Körper macht das nichts, ob's jetzt gefiltert oder eben
ungefiltert mit den ganzen Schweb- und Trübstoffen noch enthalten auf den Körper wirkt.
So und da gebe ich jetzt noch - das ist nur ein kleiner Quick Tipp für euch
falls ihr euch an den Geschmack nicht so gewöhnen könnt, oder euch das ein bisschen zu bitter schmeckt,
dann könnt ihr Agavendicksaft oder Honig ganz zum Schluss noch mit einrühren.
Ich koche die goldene Milch nie auf, ich erwärme die nur ganz leicht.
Auch mein Schwarzkümmelöl wird ja bei 30° C maximal gepresst damit alle Nährstoffe noch enthalten bleiben.
Und falls ihr jetzt aber sagt ihr möchtet das so richtig als Tee schlürfen, das soll richtig dampfen und heiß sein:
Okay, dann macht das gerne aber dann könnt ihr das Schwarzkümmelöl leider nicht verwenden.
Dann würden die ganzen Nährstoffe kaputt gehen und das wäre mega, mega schade.
Dann dürft ihr gerne kaltgepresstes Bio Kokosöl verwenden, das wäre dann z.B. die Alternative.
Aber mein Favorit ist wie gesagt hier das Schwarzkümmelöl.
Das ist jetzt die fertige goldene Milch, das nimmt eigentlich keine 3min in Anspruch.
Also das geht wirklich sehr, sehr schnell, kann man super integrieren jetzt z.B. morgens oder dann auch vielleicht mal mittags.
Guckt einfach, wie's euch am besten bekommt.
Ähm.. ich nehm' mal eben schnell 'nen Schluck.
Also zum Geschmack muss ich sagen - Ich bin jetzt ganz eiskalt und ehrlich!
Es ist jetzt kein leckerer O-Saft oder dass man sagt "Boah, den gönn' ich mir jetzt mal!"
Es ist jetzt kein Cocktail oder so aber es schmeckt nicht schlecht.
Und wenn ich mir - Also während ich das trinke, denke ich mir einfach, was es alles Gutes tut für meinen Körper.
Allein schon, dass es z.B. auch das Gedächtnis anregen kann.
Dass es einfach gut ist für mich und meinen Körper.
Das bringt mich einfach dazu, dass ich das genieße und in meine Routine mit einplane.
Probiert ihr das doch einfach gerne mal aus.
Falls euch diese Variante nicht so gut gefällt warum auch immer
oder ihr sagt: "Hey, ich möchte das jetzt einfach mal direkt ausprobieren ohne diese Paste."
Dann sage ich euch jetzt auch noch ganz schnell, wie das direkt geht.
Da nehmt ihr nämlich die ganzen einzelnen Bestandteile,
nämlich Milch, Kurkumapulver, natürlich Pfeffer, wenn ihr mögt gerne Zimt und das Öl.
Verrührt das und lasst das Ganze dann erhitzen.
Wie immer dann auch beim Öl: Gebt das Schwarzkümmelöl dann später mit dazu und erhitzt es nicht so stark.
Ja, ansonsten wünsche ich euch jetzt ganz viel Freude beim Ausprobieren.
Ich werde euch den Link zu meinen Kurkumakapseln und dem Kurkumapulver natürlich hier unten verlinken.
Und dann würde ich mich freuen, wenn ihr mir mal ein Feedback da lasst:
Habt ihr's schon mal ausprobiert? Wie findet ihr das, wie sind eure Erfahrungen damit?
Und dann können wir uns immer wieder austauschen.
Also bis zum nächsten Mal auf Kikis Kitchen, Tschüss!